in a seaside art space in Hastings East
Sussex local residents have gathered to
talk about an issue that historically
hasn't been talked about mental health
the local MP and service providers are
here to discuss what support is
available to those who are struggling
the government has committed more money
for mental health services but according
to the head of Southdown which provides
care and housing years of austerity are
having an impact we've got lots of
people dealing with lots of issues in
their lives and one of the biggest
concerns I have is that over the last 10
years of austerity we've really seen a
reduction in funding for prevention
services and that's really from the
local authority which obviously had
enormous cuts they've had to make and I
think what we're seeing which isn't
really rocket science but it's saying
that as you turn off the tap for those
prevention services the pressure builds
up on other parts of the system for
those struggling with their mental
health this couldn't be more important I
think there are great gaps in mental
health services I've received
outstanding service I've also received
the very opposite and I think if you
haven't got the confidence to negotiate
the system or you don't know how to tap
into the system to full advantage people
deathful through that it's something the
local MP amber OTT is aware of once
tipped as a conservative leadership
candidate herself she's now thrown her
considerable clout behind Jeremy Hunt so
you've been attending a mental health
summit today why is that I think it's
because I want to make sure that people
understand
the support that is available for people
of all ages with mental health
challenges actually in Hastings there
are a lot of organizations there are not
that are available to people and the
purpose of my bed this morning was to
showcase that and to make sure that
there is sufficient support to help
people with those needs are you
concerned about some of the recent
reporting about Universal Credit and
Mental Health Report for example by the
money in Mon to health policy units
saying that Universal Credit is making
people with existing mental health
problems feel very anxious ahead of
assessments 93 percent saying that
they're anxious waiting for answers but
I know that people are sometimes anxious
about universal credit and I'm keen to
dispel a lot of the myths about
universal credit actually when I talk to
people who have been nervous about going
on to universal credit they then usually
say to me actually I was worried about
it and now it's fine it's a much better
service when I talk to work coaches I
ask them what they would like to change
about universal credit and they often
say to me
our reputation actually it's a good
service well delivered and I need to
help build confidence for people who are
going on to universal credit it'll be a
positive experience it's not for
everyone
it is good for everyone it is it is a
much better service than the one it
replaces six different benefits three
different places but the real difference
and this came out this morning in the
mental health seminars I was holding
this morning is it's a personalized
tailored experience so the individual
needs are met it's not a
one-size-fits-all and one of the things
that one of the work coaches
it's about helping people get back into
work but a lot of people aren't ready
for that a lot of people with really
difficult mental health challenges
aren't ready for work and we recognize
that and will help them get ready for
work get them ready for the job market
by sunning posting a license plate are
you worried that with everything that's
going on a politics of the minute brexit
the leadership election but issues like
mental health are just not being
addressed spoken about in Westminster as
much as they chef course it is a
challenge and we have to make sure as
MPs as Secretary of State that we give
enough time and indeed volume to our own
areas and what what MPs are particularly
interested in this project and I'm
really proud that one of the things I've
been focusing here on in Hastings
it's raising awareness about mental
health giving people the confidence to
talk about it and the support they need
and where to access it now you're
backing Jeremy Hunt to the rest to be
the next leader the next prime minister
well you're a bit disappointed that he
didn't quite get enough MP used to wrap
up that race to second
well I think everybody wants their MP to
do better and any round in question but
overall Jeremy did very well we wanted
him to come second and for there to be a
good margin between him and the third
person that took place so now we were
very pleased with the outcome
were you really pleased yes no no I mean
you know nobody knew how a number of
other candidates were going to do he got
more than they got the same way thing
cos Matt and Sajid combined so he showed
himself as the clear next person after
Boris I hope we'll be able to build him
are you hoping to pick up some of Matt
Hancock's
supporters well I hope everybody we've
got less than they would have hoped
we'll think about backing Jeremy hunter
would be the best candidate you say he's
best kind of it
concern oh that that some people is
actually the continuity candidate well I
mean he's not continuity because he
offered me I think that the fact that
he's got me and penny more dirt at his
launch shows that he's a man he can he
can embrace two sides of the party that
is divided the most important thing I
think for a new leader will be to be
able to address the division not just in
the country to Parliament but amongst
MPs of our own party and Jeremy's shown
that he's been able to do that I'm
unclear of any other candidate can do
that on the show last weekend and I
asked her me hunt about her stance on
abortion and he said that he would
personally like it to be reduced the
time limit which you can get an abortion
from 24 weeks to 12 do you always when
you have iPhones Jeremy actually that
day and I spoke to him and he reassured
me as he has subsequently we're short
people publicly that he has no plans to
change the abortion laws as they start I
am very clear that any government that I
am part of that Jeremy Hunt would lead
has to be absolutely committed to
maintaining those rights as they stand
what did you say to him on that thing
well I questioned his suggestion that it
should be reduced at all I think we have
a very robust effect abortion laws and
they do not need changing
forgot women though and I accept that he
said that it's not policy that he would
seek to bring in that it's not a
conscience bait a lot of women will be
concerned at the thought that a future
Prime Minister could want to carve the
amount of time they'd not see any woman
who was concerned about that should
listen carefully to what he has
subsequently said which is that it's out
of the question any government here at
would attempt to make any changes they
can take comfort from that as I did
I remember when Bamber was a thing we
are really considering being part of
Team Boris Johnson well I prefer Jambo
first was a thing insofar as I was
talking to all the different candidates
but I think that at the end of the day
Jeremy is going to do a much better job
what happens when you had those talks
with my concern is going to be really
about delivering a brexit but also
maintaining the economy and my concern
is that some candidates are approaching
brexit with a sort of dueled I approach
and not considering the consequences to
people's jobs here in Hastings from car
manufacturing jobs up in the north all
these vital elements of building a
strong economy which depend on a strong
relationship with the European Union and
to simply say we are definitely being
October 31st and to lean into No Deal I
think is a mistake
I mean Boris Johnson has gone further
than that as well he hasn't ruled out to
Rogen or suspending Parliament in order
to push through it now which is
absolutely outrageous the only deer of
leaving the European you
in order to take back more control what
into Parliament and to consider closing
Parliament in order to deal with that is
this is the most extraordinary idea I've
ever heard
I mean War II Stewart has said that he
would be prepared to set up another
parliamentary session across the road
would you join him well I definitely use
the same colour for languages Roy but I
certainly feel just as strongly as he
does it is a ridiculous suggestion to
consider for rode compartment and first
start it would involve approaching the
Queen and that of course is it
absolutely we nobody should consider
doing that but we may have our
difficulties as MPs arriving at a
decision but the idea of involving the
Queen is completely one did you think
Bruce Johnson would make a good Prime
Minister I think Jeremy hope would make
a better one - quite on I can't I can't
rule it out because clearly Boris is in
the lead but I hope that once we go
forward and people see the debates and
see how some of the organs being put
forward by different candidates don't
really hold water they'll realise that
the best person to go with is Jeremy
your challenge with Boris's approach is
that he is saying we are definitely
leaving by October the 31st but that is
not in his gift to achieve it we'll need
support from a majority of MPs because
MPs are inventive Parliament is
thoughtful the speaker is an activist
there will be a way of stopping it and I
wish that people would go stop saying
we're definitely on October 31st when
there are so many other parts that could
come into play that will stop that so I
don't want people to be misled again
would you serve under Boris Johnson I
think it's too early to look at that
because it'll be too presumptuous of me
to think about anyone else forming a
cabinet and not knowing what place we're
gonna take but you'd accept a little
time from him now I guess I'm still
thinking very carefully about any lift
home with us I really know that
there was only men left in the
leadership context yeah it does bother
me and the Conservative Party needs to
do better at that I mean okay we can
Bank the fact that we've had two women
Prime Minister's and we're the only
party that has but the best way to get
more women in senior levels and
potentially as candidates for future
Prime Minister is to get more women
becoming MPs we only have unfortunately
just over 20% of our MPs or women we
need to get more women in the Park line
more women on the candidates this and I
and a lot of other senior women
Conservative MPs are doing our best to
encourage them does it worry that
perhaps neither in some ways like the
place for a woman in this leadership
contest is not running to be Prime
Minister it's in the kitchen having post
up snaps with them and yeah that's not
that's not the look I'm going for what I
want to encourage women to get involved
in politics I want them to find their
own role become MPs and hopefully move
up in the ministerial where I can I
think as conservatives we need to
constantly say that so that people don't
look at us and draw the wrong
conclusions when you've said previously
that you don't the party should be
parading partners in your words
consoling that isn't it I mean he took
his wife for me
you know the foreign trip to get like
those pictures didn't he the first thing
he did is campaign launch as they
where's my wife he's described her as a
secret weapon we knots parading his
partner and doing my best to try to show
that there were women involved in
Conservative Party politics who are not
partners but are out there as Secretary
of State making the case the fact is if
you're standing as Prime Minister it is
true you have to reveal more of your
personal life I think part of the
problem is that we don't have enough
women standing or any women standing for
that senior role at the moment so why
don't you run that but the way to dress
is get more in as conservative MPs at
the bottom I decided not to run I think
one of the things as a politician who
needs a certain amount of self-awareness
and I'm aware that the Conservative
Party requires really somebody who has
great enthusiasm for brexit and although
I'm committed to it
I want to treadmill carefully
some of the members of the party do not
enthusiastic committed I'm committed to
it but I do want to tread more carefully
there's some of my colleagues - what
message do you think it would send out
about the modern-day Conservative Party
if the last two people in the race are
Jeremy Hunt and Boris Johnson - white
man very went to public school and then
talks at university I mean if I was you
know a member of the Labour Party press
office I know what attacked minds I've
been using I think that actually what
people will judge us on is their ability
to engage in the debates and to make the
arguments and to show a plan we are at a
very difficult position very difficult
place as a country in our negotiations
with the European Union and our standing
in the world there are a lot of
questions going on about the United
Kingdom what we need is someone who is
going to solve that and I think that
other details are going to really come
into second place who's going to help us
solve this problem so we can move on to
what most of us came into politics to do
which is to solve the problems for
people with chance do I have
wonderful constituencies